welcome back to New Rockstars it's me
Tommy B and Transformers rise of the
Beast has just relaunched and rebooted
not one but two major franchises in a
big way yes I realized bumblebee was
technically the reboot origin but I
think of that as more of a prologue so
feel free to tell me how dumb I am in
the comments we're gonna talk about how
the film's ending actually begins this
new saga and how the post-credits scene
might be more than meets the eye warning
there will be major Major Spoilers ahead
so please proceed caution we want to
shout out nerd Riot our friends and
merch Partners who are making Amazing
Spider-Man shirts that you can now Buy
on nerdriot.chop now let's talk the
ending of this Transformers movie and
figure out what exactly happened here
the Gang has learned the transwarp key
has been broken in half as a safety
measure humans Noah and Elena travel
down to Peru to try to get the other
half before the terracons could steal it
and unleash Unicron to just snack up on
that Earth hold on to your galoshes this
ain't no Paddington Peru Adventure
Unfortunately they immediately fail and
scorching Co are able to recombine the
key and begin the slowest villain
entrance of all time seriously I
understand that Unicron is enormous but
he's moving slower than the Undertaker
at Wrestlemania after his 20th knee
surgery speaking of Undertaker at this
point in the film we must say rip air
razor Michelle yo you've had a great
year but uh you didn't last long as a
maximum the only way to stop the portal
is to enter a code that Elena has
conveniently solved which needs to be
entered in a console that can only be
accessed via people-sized tunnels
conveniently necessitating the humans to
remain involved this sets us up for our
big final battles courage you up until
this point has been a real pain in the
ass has activated the portal and now
must hold off the newly aligned Autobots
and maximals a giant Tower a Lord of the
Rings inspired in my opinion powered by
the transwarf key and perhaps the
incoming Unicron then we also have to
fight night birds they're added by
freezers and they quickly gain the upper
hand on the good guys there's two primes
now Optimus Prime and Optimus primal and
they gang up on battle trap but it's
Primal that rips off his arm and beats
him to death with his own wrecking ball
good God this is one of the most violent
scenes I've seen in any movie just
because it's Transformers doesn't mean
it wasn't making me go oh meanwhile our
human friends Elena and Nora are
frantically running through the tunnels
of the tower created by that transwarp
key like I said unfortunately Scourge
discovers Noah pulls him out nearly
killing him before Mirage Shields him
from scourge's cannon fire now I thought
for a second Mirage was dead but instead
he's just seriously effed up it's like
me after one of my high school football
games King cust unkissed and full of
pizza as a last-ditch effort he
transforms around Noah becoming his Exo
Suit now fans the G1 cartoon will
remember the first depiction of the exo
suit was worn by Spike whitwick later a
similar suit was provided for Daniel
weight Wiki with fruit able to transform
into an all-terrain vehicle this suit
was subsequently enhanced via the nebula
binary bonding process to become
Daniel's Headmaster suit that he
connected to RC RC appears in this movie
so perhaps we will see these bonding
suits in future installments with his
new suit Noah tries to fight Scourge but
it's pretty clear he's outmatched and it
looks like it might be curtains for Noah
and Mirage until Optimus Prime shows up
to back him up unfortunately this is
about the time that Unicron begins
breaching through the portal and sending
tons of drones crashing down towards her
things are looking pretty damn bleak
until oh my God it's bumblebees music
that's right don't call it a comeback
he's been B for years you heard me after
infusion of Energon which is of course
the preferred fuel of the Transformer
race takes many forms I found out
including ore Crystal gas and raw energy
but it's most commonly used by the
Transformers in its liquid state which
is stored in many different mediums most
famously the Energon Cube and if you
think I wrote that all myself you're
crazy thank you to better help for
sponsoring this video movies and TV can
be great escapism but when it's time to
face things head on better help is here
to help better help is the world's
largest therapy service and is 100
online with better help you can tap into
a network of over 30 000 licensed and
experienced therapists who can help you
with a wide range of issues and trust me
baby I got a wide range to get started
just answer a few questions about what
you're looking for from therapy and what
your preferences are they're helpful
then match you with a therapist from
their Network that's right for you after
that talk to your therapist however you
feel comfortable whether it's via text
chat phone or video call I send to Raven
you can message your therapist at any
time and schedule live sessions when
it's convenient for you if your
therapist isn't a right fit for any
reason you can switch to a new therapist
at no additional charge better help
gives you the same level of
professionalism and quality you expect
from in-office therapy but with a
therapist who is custom picked for you
more scheduling flexibility and at a
more affordable price and that's
important get 10 off your first month at
betterhelp.com new rockstars that's
b-e-t-t-e-r-h-e-l-p.com Slash new
rockstars for 10 off your first month of
therapy give yourself the gift of
therapy hitching a ride on Stratosphere
bumblebee drops down and begins
dispatching of all the drones while
shooting at Scourge Nightwing flies up
to engage him but bumblebee ends up
using her as a human shield or Terracon
Shield he then dispatches over in what
would have been the best kill if Primal
hadn't literally just smashed battle
tracks with his own wrecking ball
moments earlier he rips her Wing off
stabs her with it she explodes in the
sky I kid you not this movie is brutal I
know it's CGI it's still brutal I'm
almost out of breath here this whole
time Elena is running from a freezer
trying to get to the console entering
the access code even though she manages
to enter it Council gets destroyed in
The Scourge in Prime fight Scourge asks
Unicron to send in more reinforcements
and Unicron does and we finally get to
see the scorpionox that us real
Gearheads will remember first appeared
in the 2007 Transformers movies as well
as one of the sequels Revenge of the
Fallen fortunately the Autobots of
maximals at this point are a well-oiled
machine much like my beloved Buffalo
Bills and their leader Josh Allen and
they were able to handle the drones
freezers and scorpionax while Prime kill
Scourge in another brutal fashion kill
also a reclaiming Bumblebee's emblem
this belongs to a friend of mine is what
he says I don't know I said that in a
Hulk Hogan voice but I like it keep it
in editors damn the good guys are Savage
in this one like I said before the
battle destroyed the console so the only
option left for Optimus Prime is to
sacrifice himself for probably one
thousandth dimes between the comics TV
show and various movies but oh no my
friends humanoa is more than meets the
eye this time he comes to Optimus
Prime's Aid helping him destroy the
trans word the trapping Unicron in the
process you know we love an initial suck
in and uh there's a huge suck in at this
point of Unicron being sucked back out
of the out of Earth it almost sucks in
Noah and Optimus Prime luckily they make
it out alive and Primal then says
Unicron is not dead the Unicorn is
instead trapped and good return Optimus
Prime says let him come instead of let
them come from the trailer so they
tricked us and I really hope you guys
enjoyed these appetizers because here's
where the ending really gets wild the
whole beginning of the film was all
about Noah trying to get a job to help
his brother afford the medical treatment
he desperately needs the end of the film
finds Noah in another job interview this
time with a construction company the
foreman starts the interview off normal
but then reveals he knows Noah helps
save the world in Peru huh how does he
know that and as a thank you he says his
secret government agency will pay for
Noah's brother's treatment agent Burke
as this man is revealed to me asks him
and his big friends to join them as we
are in the middle of an ongoing War
which you may remember is is a line from
this TV spot we're in the middle of an
ongoing War you then handsome a business
card tweaks a plaque on the wall it
opens to reel a base and hanger thing
and there's a familiar vehicle and just
as I was like where do I know that from
Noah flips over the card and it says G I
Joe on the back holy Hasbro
Cinematic Universe we've seen these guys
in the comics we've seen and loved the
toys but now here we are finally getting
it on the big screen where do I think
Noah is going to be next well Anthony
Ramos is a mega star we now see he's
been invited to join the GI go so it
would make sense and also continue on
the theme of humans not being as
important in this franchise to move him
over to a GI Joe franchise I think that
these characters will be in both movies
they'll be GI ghost and Transformers is
this a complete GI Joe reboot I hope so
remember the year is 1994 so this is
before the GI Joe movies we previously
had plenty of time to reboot that's the
whole new set of drills what's next for
the maximals well they in the Autobots
now know of each other's existence
Optimus primal has bonded with his
namesake Optimus Prime I don't know how
that works maybe it's the other way
around I think now that they have that
Valley with Energon the maximals can
begin to seek an escape off of this
Earth if they want I also because I know
how movies work believe we'll probably
see them in a sequel or perhaps a Beast
Wars movie so let's talk this
post-credancy in the mid-credit scene we
see Noah putting the finishing touches
on a junker card made up of different
parts in Surprise the thing just
transforms into a red and silver Mirage
it's kind of funny my first car was a
yellow car with a white door and this
reminded me of that the colors are all
mismatched so it looks like Noah managed
to restore him from the exo suit and now
know his friend reek is aware so I think
reek is actually the first recruiting of
the GI goes that's my theory of what
this post-credit scene means now here's
my overall thoughts on the Move
bumblebee was the reboot but this really
feels like a relaunch of the franchise
now we're clearly setting up Unicron as
the big bad but with him being stuck it
allows for some Decepticon duplicity
over the next film or two why not
reintroduce a new Megatron why not
reintroduce a new Starscream betraying
Megatron I like that the humans were not
the main focus of this film and
especially at the end it made sense
because they're branching Noah off to
these GI Joe's and this these films are
going to be combined in Cinematic
Universe there's no need to have a main
human character as a through line in
this franchise it's all about the
Autobots baby please don't forget to
check out our many great merch options
follow me at Tommy back gold follow new
rock stars on all social platforms be
sure to subscribe to our channel here on
YouTube for analysis of everything you
love thanks for watching and remember
let them come
foreign
[Music]